you
they are installed era after present era
Nobel Prize targeting a facility Allah
medicine it is a great honor to
introduce the Nobel laureates in
Physiology or medicine professor John
Okeefe
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of my colleagues may bridge
and Edward Moser and myself I would like
to express our gratitude to the Nobel
Foundation for hosting this magnificent
banquet the venue is absolutely
magnificent the food is as we would say
where I come from scrumptious and I
think the idea of organizing the dessert
and that wonderful pattern of six little
desserts in the form of a hexagonal
symmetrical hexagonal array so
reminiscent of the grid cells discovered
by the Moses is nothing short of
culinary genius
I would also like to express our
gratitude to the Nobel Committee and
assembly for deeming our research worthy
of this distinguished accolade
I think it's near to say that the Nobel
Prize is the highest honor any scientist
or artist can achieve
we are both pleased and delighted of
course we see the awards is a
recognition not only of ourselves and
our own accomplishments but also of our
collaborators in the study of the
spatial functions of the hippocampus and
our colleagues in the wider field of
cognitive and behavioral neuroscience
it's really been a great area to work in
and it's been very nice to have all
these people as our friends cognitive
neuroscience is entering an exciting era
in which new technologies and ideas are
making it possible to study in a neural
basis of cognition perception memory and
emotion at the level of networks of
interacting neurons the level at which
we believe many of the important
operations of the brain actually take
place
we're in know a considerable amount
about how individual neurons work and
how two cells communicate with each
other but the way in which entire
networks of thousands of neurons
cooperation interact with each other and
are orchestrated to create our ideas and
concepts is an under explored area it is
probably also at this level and the
failure at this level that many of the
most disturbing and intractable diseases
of the mind and brain take place this
new era of neuroscience has been made
possible by the development of new
optical computer based electronic and
molecular biology tools that are being
brought into neuroscience from from
other areas such as physics and
chemistry and these will allow us to
monitor the activity of many thousands
of cells simultaneously and to
manipulate their activity so we will
move from looking at correlations
between brain activity and
just studying how the brain actually
causes mental states and behavior is
fitting therefore that our fellow no
llores this year in physics and
chemistry are world leaders in providing
us with some of these tools and I would
like to salute them and actually we're
quite eagle to usually looking forward
to beginning to use some of their laser
based optical techniques we're also
pleased to be receiving the surprises
with laureates from so many different
countries I think in this era of growing
xenophobia it's important to remember
that science is the quintessential
international endeavor and the sterling
reputation of the Nobel awards is partly
due to the widely perceived lack of bias
on the national or other biased level in
the selection of the laureates I think a
scientists we believe that the future
great contributions to our understanding
of the physical and the biological world
can come from citizens of any country in
any part of the world so it is the
credit of the Nobel committees that they
have steadfastly endeavored to follow
Alfred Nobel's wishes that the prizes
recognize contributions to the welfare
of humanity regardless of color of
country of origin gender race or
religious affiliation so in conclusion I
want to end by recognizing and thanking
our many collaborators and colleagues
and they're obviously too numerous to
mention in this short speech so our
universities UCL and NTNU and our
generous funders several of whom are
actually here and have taken the time to
come in and celebrate this occasion with
so thank you for your occasion talk